hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to let's play Garry's
Dirk's no Gary dark secret it's not Gary
he's dark secret Gary's the guy who's
playing [ __ ] you hello oh it's a big
clock okay
anybody
Oh was that actually a monster I've been
hearing monster noises the entire time
give you lots of tinderboxes but not
much to life
I don't think that was actually a
monster the music didn't even change and
once again there's nothing in here yeah
house nothing I have nothing nothing
whatsoever after they've been doing a
lot of noises lots of noises I guess
with the intent to creep me out
well [ __ ] and hell ah I knew I should
have known alright oh now they're giving
no no they're not even give me stuff
light down here and he behind you huh
nothing okay yeah I should have known
that was pretty much obvious gonna
happen
oh here's finally God been using way too
much of my battery just weird sayin and
these are games to say the least
okay that's the way back up I think
hello ah a lever it's a celebrity for I
guess fat defeat I should head back to
the archives and look for head secret
just trying to be thorough good thing I
came back or else I would have been lost
forever anything behind you huh no yes
no it's kind of disturbing the hand in
the flashlights are like wicked big
holding them up right here to my eyeball
cuz that's how normal people hold
flashlights ah this is ah I know what
this is for
I know exactly what this is for haha so
smart I'm so smart and strong look at me
look at me okay rotate it ever so
slightly ever so slightly gently now
gently and then a little more and then I
drop it [ __ ]
well [ __ ] I [ __ ] up that one alright
take to get up there get nice and stock
[ __ ]
maybe there's a stack of boxes you got
here fine do it this way
cuz I love to stack things I love to
stack oh it's my favorite minigame in
the world
I've been thinking about marrying it cuz
I love it so much can't even jump over a
box when I'm holding a box okay don't
get irregular now get regular not
irregular okay another box get over
there
I uh at least I saw the wisdom of the
solution I mean knowing is half the
battle right right right right right
guys enough damn Oh up wait ah ha ha
yeah that's right I got it I'm the best
yes sir click click ah
a few oh oh oh battery that was actually
like for battery loot and a box I'm the
best ah ain't no doubt now oh that's it
I'll crap I've been using my battery way
too much Oh
[Music]
oh that was in going out of the
Louisville wasn't it I think so hahaha
what you scared old monster scared of me
I'm not that ugly
alright this is now gonna be sad let's
play cuz I'm so ugly monsters run away
okay so the lever opened up a secret
route route okay
all right OOP god damn it's just a
painting not even a good painting I
should be more concerned given that
there are murderers in this house oh you
better think twice about that my friend
did you knock this over was this knocked
over before oh hello ah is this root out
oh my I must feel the Tucker why why
must I seal the door oh no oh I must
feel this door oh boy
Oh lock it
there we go good job war block ha ha
help what I must seal the door I did I
thought I did
I must seal the door
I must seal the door that do it I must
seal this door
maybe if I fish this fish you are
[ __ ] now oh damn he was right there I
was also a delayed reaction on my part
oh you realize what I was looking at
okay I know it I'm like freaking obvious
now what do you say seal the door you
know they're cool deliver all right yeah
I get it
he's coming he's coming he's coming
Kurt Jahnke well have a seal the door oh
hello Jeff I think you're using my
massive muscles picking up barrels and
whatnot like I did not get lucky or he
fell I don't know which oh it's feet or
one way in his hands or the other
grody
anyway
ah
necie that sounded sticky
okay cool they obviously don't know how
to seal doors unlike me who's like a pro
doors okay there's nothing in there
there's some creepy-ass stashes yeah I
mean you'd think that a whole house full
of party guests could take on one grunt
it won't open but the lock seams hold it
weak do I need a hammer to go with this
chipper nope apparently not apparently I
do not but I'll go there in a second
if I want to take this route I need to
find something to remove the boards with
move the boards that's the way to do ah
helpful wind how nice is that that
actually lights candles ah life go thank
you for the batteries but uh please put
some clothes on
well what's this in here Wow look at the
miniature one of those things laudanum
or morphine it's not as fun to say lava
upper living room key well let's explore
shall we is where those people died I
believe
[Music]
they weren't good at hiding
I can tell oh look it's their mangled
corpse at least they left
factory okay anyway back to serious why
haven't they just the monster has come
for me I don't at least jump off the
balcony and try to grab onto one of the
trees it was like between me and dying a
horrible death from a giant monster
thing I think I'd go for the other yeah
and that's the unhelpful wind goodbye
watch these Pro hiding skills
really oh I see you hey how's it going
obviously these guys didn't know how to
hide very well
they lost hide and see to he seek a limb
that never would never mind it ain't
worth it
hello gone it's you leave oh hello
maybe I can somehow BuChE BuChE mouth
about me Oh
I got kind of looking at the monster oh
there is yeah apparently even looking
through this little gap does not bode
well for me oh man he is persistent oh
no is he coming this way oh no oh no oh
no oh oh coming for me
I've never oh well he's not going away
is he I thought maybe I'd just go
ah
you didn't hear a thing buddy I'll use
going away good leg yes that fell down
with some force now go to the grunts
room nope I won't I lied about that I'm
a dirty dirty liar but now I can plow my
way through those boards you ready
you're ready for this test of strength
you're ready for this you're ready
you're ready oh and I'm out of time
thank you all so much for watching and
as always I will see you in the next
part
bye bye
[Music]